that's why because I have a clause I'm
back here if you don't like back you
look like a mini human being we supposed
to look there Casey Neistat told me
that's why you wear sunglasses what's
the deal with the blue sunglasses
alright so we just did a podcast was
awesome right there's really good what
do we talk about we talked about the
Better Project mm-hmm I thought that we
talk more about plant food but I don't
want to talk about that there like a lot
of brilliant things saying I've got a
name drive Micah risk is she's my food
coach former former podcast guess what
number you know whatever my I don't know
what number I don't know
what 500 or no no I'm going to air it
yet yeah it was pretty bad look what
Brogan brought me do you know what pose
it is ritual
this is treecko's tree pose and an RA
man doing arm extension that's brilliant
yeah where can you get these on the
internet I think you just search I have
no idea sir army man Treecko well it is
gonna come out before that I don't know
what we're doing I don't know we're
doing here we did a podcast it's awesome
it was actually a much more serious
podcast than he's allowing himself to we
talked about human connection we talked
about digital gain strategy we talked
about the build of no veteran project
the movement what it is we talked about
how to build a movement authenticity we
talked about yeah the power of the power
of community to really not just get
people out the door and active but
really change culture we did great
we good breather it was awesome was i
nervous yeah how were you I was on there
this is the best podcast you've ever
been apart it was the best one I've ever
heard over the fire okay so listen in
you can find it on iTunes you can find
it at rich worldcom I'll put all the
links below check it out and stay true
get it with this one over the silo rises
without all the I rich roll
signing up all right
[Music]